[Música]
y
colombia no es un país desigual y creo
que todos estamos aquí y todos sabemos
que hay cero pobreza verdad hay cero
problemas de gente con alimentación con
salud educación y todo eso y es por eso
que quisiera que hiciéramos muy fuerte
aplauso para los gobiernos de los
últimos 30 años que resolvieron ese
problema por completo
y bueno
entonces si estamos de acuerdo que hay
desigualdad juzgando porque ninguno de
ustedes se dio por aplaudir a ninguna de
estas bellezas tropicales podemos
acordar que hay demasiado problema y es
por eso que me gusta de punto que
hagamos una encuesta aquí interna con la
gente que no aplaudió quién es el
culpable de la desigualdad en colombia
hasta la mano si creen que son las
empresas
el gobierno
las manos los individuos
también estamos en buen camino bueno la
culpa también es de nosotros todos todos
hacemos parte del problema y me hicieron
hacer énfasis en esto que este es mi
opinión no la de ted que todos somos
ingenuos etcétera y si el tabaco es
nocivo para la salud pero bueno es otro
tema lo importante aquí es que vamos a
hacer un paréntesis y entender cómo la
tecnología afecta en la historia la
sociedad y los diferentes efectos sobre
el tema de desigualdad debe dar un
ejemplo todas estas cosas que tenemos
acá que eran estos todos empezaron como
juguetes de ricos hoy en día si ustedes
miran tienen tres de esos en su bolsillo
todo el mundo tiene un celular con
cámara donde tiene acceso a toda la
información del resto de la humanidad
verdad y eso es lo bonito porque porque
la tecnología al principio tiene un alto
costo y a medida de que va pasando por
el tema de adopción a medida que va
pasando de los innovadores hasta los
rezagados ahí empieza
la población que se vuelve algo y
commodities verdad ya deja de tener el
efecto que tiene el principio de
requerir un alto costo porque el volumen
es bajo y es por eso que ya vemos con
una tecnología verdad se masifica y eso
es lo más importante porque a pesar de
que algunos aquí piensan que la
tecnología nos va a matar hace buenas
historias de ciencia ficción y son
divertidas terminator etcétera pero eso
solamente es porque porque toda la
innovación al principio parece una
amenaza y le pueda dar el ejemplo cuando
los ascensores dejaron de tener
operadores la gente que tenía miedo
decían lista locura que es y hoy nos
montamos los sensores todos los días y
los manejamos como si no fuera nada iba
a pasar muy próximamente con todo el
tema de tiene inteligencia artificial
porque por miedo esto queda lo que no
conocemos en este momento ya está
pasando la gente dice cómo vamos a
manejar los carros sin inteligencia es
difícil sin
y la historia que ustedes ven se repite
y nunca pasa nada y nos adaptamos en 20
años va a ser lo común entonces más que
tenerle miedo hay que tener en cuenta de
que esto va a transformar y uno no va a
eliminar trabajos la gente habla la
inteligencia artificial por ejemplo va a
eliminar los trabajos va a dejar la
sociedad en la en la inmunda
de todo dicen y eso no va a pasar porque
el link ha pasado entonces porque
esperamos que esta vez si va a ser
diferente esta es diferente porque
estamos nosotros vivos y viviendo lo
pero si ustedes miran cómo ha cambiado
las cosas en los 70 y 80 cuando
empezaron a salir las bases de datos
relacionales decían el gobierno ahora va
a tener el control de todo el mundo
porque va a tener la información a su
acceso ilimitado de todo lo que nosotros
sabemos de forma muy fácil y efectiva ok
que pasó nada si es decir si exigen
siendo igual de ineficientes que siempre
ojalá tuvieran ese control que nosotros
pensábamos en los 70 que iban a suceder
pero no sucedió tampoco va a suceder con
esto entonces
programa de colombia produce un volvamos
al tema de desigualdad el tema de
desigualdad es clave y debemos tener
claro que hay tres actores desigual
distas que están aportando de forma
igual quiero entrar y explicarles cómo y
qué podemos hacer
la tecnología permite que todo sea más
eficiente la tecnología no resuelve
problemas y eso es un tema importante de
tener en cuenta qué significa eso si un
proceso funciona con papel y lápiz con
tecnología va a ser mejor porque va a
ser más escalable tal vez más rápido
pero no significa que si no hemos
resuelto el problema no lo van a
resolver no es una reunión hace unos
meses una clienta donde dice y qué
podemos hacer con la inteligencia
artificial y yo le dije ya tienen el
problema resuelto en excel o en papel o
en algo no es que piensas hacer con
inteligencia artificial si no lo sabes
resolver por fuera no lo va a resolver
con esto al menos que haya aquí unos
asteriscos de ciertas cosas de la
ciencia y cosas que ya son muy avanzadas
pero para pedir el horóscopo sirio va a
funcionar muy bien entonces alineando
los tres actores empezando con las
empresas que podemos hacer las empresas
tienen una sola función creer que tienen
otra
irrisorio porque hay un grupo de
personas que se reúnen con una misión no
van
mágicamente a hacer otra cosa un equipo
de fútbol que lo ponen a jugar béisbol
le va a ir mal film el ejemplo puntual
michael jordan basquetbolista excelente
fue a jugar béisbol y el dolor verse por
la cola ante las piernas entonces qué
significa eso las empresas saben hacer
plata y si no empezamos a hacer plata
desaparece entonces que tengan
iniciativas al turistas bacano pero no
podemos depender de ellos entonces cómo
hacemos para que las empresas hagan más
plata usando la tecnología para escalar
procesos como las mencionadas un momento
y qué significa eso si ellos pueden
crear procesos que reduzcan el costo de
servir a las personas menos
favorecidas en ese momento van a poder
expandir el mercado inicial en el que
participan porque una empresa por
ejemplo financiera va a tender a
prestarle al que puede pagar pero ese no
es la persona que necesita la plata
verdad una empresa financiera le toca
tener una estructura de costos altísima
con las sucursales cada dos cuadras no
entiendo por qué lo necesitan en el 2019
pero bueno así es el des que pasa las
personas que están en en lugares remotos
que de pronto necesitan el campesino
para poder
sembrar crecer no tiene donde acceder a
esas cosas porque no hay sucursal
cercana la más cercana les queda
haciendo semillas entonces el punto de
todo esto es hay que alinear la empresa
para que haga más plata pero aquí viene
un tema cómo nos aseguramos de que las
las empresas ricas o grandes no se
vuelvan más grandes y los pobres más
pobres en general porque ese es el
problema y el que siempre sale hacen
reformas tributarias para bajar los
impuestos y usualmente ni siquiera se ve
reflejado a corto plazo en el incremento
de empleo entonces qué es lo que está
pasando esto esto es sencillo la
dinámica de mercado a largo plazo tiende
a tener éxito esa dinámica de mercado es
entre más utilidad tengan las empresas
verdad más competencia va a llegar si
dejan sus utilidades muy altas que les
va a pasar
se van a desaparecer porque no tiene
sentido pero porque los van a atacar por
todos lados o el gobierno va a entrar a
hacer su labor que es regular ok el
actor número 2 el gobierno este es el
más interesante porque es más
interesante porque es el que sabe esto
hermano es perdón que regular y eso es
importante porque ellos tienen una sola
misión pero pero cuando salen las
elecciones esos males nos van a llevar
hasta la luna y al final no hacen nada
entonces si nosotros logramos por
ejemplo reducir ese scope que tiene el
gobierno ahora mismo de tratar de hacer
todo ese pocos programas todo ese poco
iniciativas que se inventan nombres cada
vez mejores y eslogan de marketing de
juba que ganarían premios si no
funcionan a competir eso no es la labor
del gobierno dejemos que ellos hagan lo
que saben hacer
y hago un paréntesis aquí porque sería
imposible hacer un
una mención del gobierno sin hablar de
lo que está pasando en colombia en este
momento las protestas
tienen un tema y es asumen el gobierno
es el único responsable de todo lo malo
que está pasando no que no tengan la
culpa ojo ahí no estoy del lado del
gobierno pero tampoco estoy del lado de
las protestas estoy en la mitad
efe en la mitad porque creo en la no
polarización y les pido que dejen de
pelear con sus amigos dejen de pelear
con sus familiares y dejemos de jugar el
juego que los políticos quieren que
otros juguemos donde ellos son los que
se ven beneficiados si nosotros nos
ponemos a pelear entre nosotros en
whatsapp en personas en los bares en
todas partes quién va a ganar políticos
estamos dando publicidad gratis entonces
ya pagando el tema de política volvamos
a la charla y el objetivo acá es que la
tecnología permita incrementar la
competencia y al mismo tiempo al volver
al gobierno en teoría más eficiente
quitarle responsabilidad para que puedan
hacer las pocas cosas bien hechas esa es
la misión de lo que estamos tratando
aquí de lograr ahora creo que cada uno
de ustedes sabe mejor que cualquier
político y que cualquier empresa que es
lo que necesita cada uno de ustedes eso
no es
esta gente no sabe lo que quiere pero
bueno espero
entonces si saben lo que necesitan esto
esto es importante porque
alineando el éxito de los dos primeros
actores verdad que es mayor
utilidades para las empresas mayores
impuestos para que hagan programas y de
esa forma puedan empezar a eliminar toda
la desigualdad que hay en todos los
sectores verdad porque no solamente es
gobierno no es solamente las empresas
vendiendo a sectores que ya tienen todo
lo que necesitan sino va más allá y como
alineamos para que salga ganando el
actor más importante ustedes ese es el
fin de todo eso la tecnología logra eso
como democratizando las herramientas de
trabajo la tecnología permite que cada
uno de ustedes pueda lograr grandes
cosas en el área que quieran puede ser
en salud puede ser en la música arte no
tiene que ser temas de software
está en nuestras manos ser menos
desigual distas
y eso es lo más importante y lo que
quiero que se lleve gracias no no no no
me faltaba algo me faltaba algo y no me
van a aplaudir ok no me importa pero
aquí va que significa desigual dista
esto lo más importante palabra inventada
o sea que no según la real academia
española desigual dista es individuo
entidad que se cree que la culpa de la
desigualdad que le afecta es culpa del
otro y no hace nada para combatirla
entonces aquí se los dejo la palabra use
la si quiere hashtag etcétera etcétera y
que lo hagan al diseño
yo no soy desigual dista o menos creo
que no lo soy porque porque uso la
tecnología que me herramienta cuando uno
tiene un martillo todos los problemas
son claros y todos los problemas que yo
veo lastimosamente los veo con un
solución el software lo podemos resolver
con una app o es una página resolvería
esa vaina a veces sí a veces no me
engañó a veces pero lo importante es
esto hago eso y lo hago esto para
emprendedores para empresas y para todo
tipo de entidades ayudarlos a escalar
sus procesos usando la tecnología verdad
hay una cosa muy importante como les
decía todos aquí tenemos los
dispositivos más poderosos de
computación que han tenido en la
historia lo tienen en el bolsillo
algunos apuntando más a este momento le
puede dañar la cámara del celular porque
soy bien malo hasta que deje de tomarle
fotos
tienen eso y tienen acceso a todo el
conocimiento de la historia la humanidad
y pueden acceder con un post para que
millones de personas hagan y vean algo
algo que ya cambia el mundo pero si
insistimos en utilizar los celulares y
los dispositivos más poderosos del mundo
para ver cómo nos veríamos cuando seamos
viejos
está bien está bien si ven que el
edificio civil malo entonces aquí es
donde está por favor no seamos desigual
vistas cambiemos no solamente una vez
cada cuatro años con salimos a votar
sino todos los días y los invito a no
ser recibo artistas ahora sí